over in Oklahoma City three riders are
arrested for terrorism quote this is not
Seattle says County Attorney I love that
he actually said that I'm glad he did
and me too man like yeah this is a where
you know regular Americans live nah
Seattle if you want some of that stuff
so I mean look let's let's be real this
is the story yeah right we don't need to
go to much in detail about and that's it
make sure you smash that like button and
subscribe to this we don't what I'm
saying is I don't need to read through
here and tell you the names of the
people and how they're you know jazz and
all the specifics yeah the news here is
finally something is being done yes
finally you've got people who are saying
like you see this huge book in my right
hand
wham right in the face boom you know
that you know that that comic that meme
of Batman smack and Robin yes that's
what it feels like their life we're
peacefully wham with the book they go
flying
finally protest and then this this is
not the only case I mean I don't have
anything offhand but I'm seeing it all
over the place DOJ where people are just
like no more we're done with this
the DOJ announced for people being
charged over the Andrew Jackson one of
them got arrested that's you to warrant
they tried this person down man these
people are they're dangerously insane
you know and I don't mean that to be
disrespectful to people I'm not trying
to disparage the differently-abled I
mean quite literally these people are
being preyed upon by extremists mm-hmm
and we see this with what happened in
Louisville because you heard about what
happened in Louisville right I'm not
sure what happened so this guy who's
clearly unwell was a part of the riots a
part of the the protests in the park is
an occupation style protest okay and all
these people are like it's a peaceful
protest in Louisville they're just
camping this guy was arrested twice it
was twice right yeah yes for a riding
charges okay all right and he's
handcuffing himself he's doing this
activism so apparently gets into a fight
with some people in the park with the
peaceful protesters who had previously
been arrested for rioting okay they
throw him out and so he walks he's at
the edge of the park and he takes a
handgun and he fires twice in the air
and then just aim starts firing randomly
into the park oh man killed it killed a
photographer shot in the face and then
some other people returned fire I guess
him
and took him down and then he came he
got arrested this guy wasn't was was one
of the activists with black lives matter
would have been arrested for rioting and
he had a gun he had two mags and
apparently when he was arrested the
first time they caught him with the
weapons really and they released him
apparently really is what I read it I
could be wrong so make sure you guys
fact you me on this one I read that when
he was arrested the police arrested him
with this firearm
- Annie was legal it was legal though
okay and so I don't know if the argument
is here but he got released he got
released in had his weapon and he is
insane he's criminally you know deranged
dude Wow I don't know man I feel like
that how did he end up with this weapon
a lot of a lot of people on the left
think is conspiracy they're like no the
police staged this I'm like me the guy's
crazy
everyone everyone knew he was people in
the park we're talking about it they're
like we know this guy is so he's only
been charged with murder and wanton
endangerment
what how does this guy not get charged
with terrorism yeah right I guess
because the motive was just like passion
crime hmm
the thing about these people in Oklahoma
see which is interesting is that you
know terrorism is the political
motivation it's like it's like a it's
like almost like a hate crime yeah hate
crime is about identity terrorism is
about ideology so these people commit a
crime to push an ideology you hear you
get locked up mm-hmm it feels like black
lives matter has like four different
tendrils coming out and they all
everyone at the ends of each one are so
drastically different about how they do
things and and what they believe it's
like they're not the same group at all
this is part of far-left tactics it's
called the diversity of tactics and in
my opinion it's a way to manipulate you
know dopey lefty regular Americans who
are stupid don't understand what's going
on yeah so what happens is oftentimes
you'll see these protests where you know
doofy old Americans are bopping about
their little pink hats on holding up
little signs that say nonsensical things
like ban assault rifles you're like
those are already banned that make it
illegal already yeah and so they don't
know they didn't even what they're
protesting for in order to weaponize
that ignorance they tell these people if
you see someone coming crime you have to
respect the diversity of tactics
that's the most insane thing I've ever
heard no way that's insane
imagine if you were like going to war
and one general is like I am going to
mass my troops on these two fronts and
move forward and crush their capital on
the other side they're like we should
send our troops to defend this or we
should also send our troops to the sea
or to the desert it's like way way way
hold on we have no plan there's no
diversity of tactics we need to we need
we need tactics to use you can't just
randomly do things right the reason they
do that is it's an excuse that sounds
like it makes sense and that way they
can manipulate these people who are
unwell and stupid into doing what they
actually need so the reality is the
diversity of tactics they claim is
actually just they're tricking you into
doing being the shields for their
violence nope exactly so there there
have been stories about this where
they'll actually these activists plan
this out they'll say we're gonna have a
big group of people who are just gonna
be holding up signs we need to lead them
into this street illegally so they get
arrested two reasons the first they want
these people to get arrested so that it
radicalizes them they get angry they say
I don't understand why am I being
arrested n do anything wrong I'm
protesting then these organizations say
we'll bail you out right we're here for
you okay and the other issue is it
creates as a mat a massive disturbance
do you think that's what happened in st.
Louis
I think someone did that for what led
them into it because it was a private
street that they they went through the
gate you know that the yes so it was a
it was a private lot they went through a
private gate that said no trespassing
they just went through and they're like
they were yelling all the videos of them
yelling we're on the sidewalk we're in
the street but it was a private street
then they weren't allowed to be on and
the organizers I'd be willing to bet
knew this I'm sure yeah so they were
going to the mayor's house you guys may
have seen the story you got this those
memes going crazy
oh man about this couple there they're
delicious with his rifle and her and her
handgun and they have no idea how to how
to hold weapons or use them there are
several points where he actually like he
muzzles his wife he like points the gun
at her oh really he's not paying
attention it's like he's just pointed at
her and as I'm sure is loaded where
she's behind him and she's like this
with their gun pointed at his his head
too like did your voice sure just like
the camera
dicks showing it looks like it does look
like she looks like she's standing wave
far behind him though so no no like
they're staying next to each other
there's there's video where it's like
she's standing behind him like this and
it looks and she has her finger yeah I
mean and there's also photos I think
they were prepared to shoot these people
though and all I do there's a video of
her walking towards it looks like the
crowd with the gun with the gun pointed
yeah so here's the thing here's the
thing
hundred percent mm-hm it's confirmed by
everybody it is yeah this is a private
community it's gated you need a key to
get into it mm-hmm
the way the the the couple explained it
is that it's like he claims I guess or
what someone some resident as soon as
you walk in that gate it's like being in
someone's living room
legally oh okay the argument being that
like we can just just shoot you yeah you
just you just broke legally they could
have right so that's the big debate
happening right now
of course all these lefty publications
are like oh they're gonna go to jail
that was against peaceful protesters
that were breaking into their living
room basically breaking into their
community yeah because I don't know if
you can legally argue that a private
street constitutes your living room well
weren't they yelling that they were
gonna kill him that's what the couple
said the couple said that the the guy
said that he was having dinner at his
pet at his patio and these people
started like trying to break in because
you need a key yeah that's a parent
that's what's been reported out okay so
you know if it's not true that's just
what it was written by a local outlet
okay so they break in the gate wasn't
smashed at first but at some point did
get smashed up I don't know why and he
said that first he told mrs. private
property you can't come in here and they
started yelling things and I'm like you
know fu will burn your house down you
know will kill you things like that out
we've heard that stuff before yeah look
in New Mexico you know we I don't know I
don't know exactly what that guy yelled
it may have been like he's gonna kill
you or we're gonna kill he's harder to
know what he said yeah but we've heard
people like yell these things about
threatening the lives of other people so
these are people who they're not only
that they they're seeing people actually
beat people up people are actually being
assaulted and Louis by dasai rioters
yeah exactly by their own people right
exactly nobody knew you got you got a
video coming out of Louisville where a
guy standing as you're parked on the
edge of the park just firing into the
into the crowd right so when a group of
P
start coming in and these two these two
people said that they look like they
they said they were armed these people
are weapons they went out their weapons
yeah but back to the main point you
mentioned about a lot of people not
knowing it these these people who
marched had no idea none whatsoever
probably not and you know it's crazy
they could have gotten killed yep these
kid you know what man stupid games these
kids don't understand what they're
getting themselves into and so you have
in the Chad's now the fifth shooting in
and I think like five or six days fifth
and it was it was like two kids it was
like 16 and 14 years old right they
messed up little kids are getting him
well they were driving a car or
something happened they said that the
activists are like oh they rammed the
barrier or something well they were
trying to claim and there's a lot of
videos of them talking about how the
white SUV was driving around in circles
shooting into the Chazz I didn't hear
that though in livestream so I've seen
different videos there's a many
different videos from different
viewpoints and it doesn't prove anything
cuz each thing is like kind of a
different instance you're already
hearing gunshots go off so there's
things are already happening but in that
video that we watched earlier you
clearly hear a gun from a fairly heavy
rifle going off pop hop hop hop hop and
then you hear the hitting yeah the
barricade I don't know there's also a
video where of love there's a video
where three guys are walking and they're
like if you want to be saved get to the
police precinct now it was like is your
last warning and then all of a sudden
you hear pops and they run towards it
did they know is this going to happen
why were they telling people like it to
the police precinct now if you want to
be safe it's your last warning
last warning for what why was well it
was what they happen ten seconds later
gunshots they run towards them what do
they know maybe nothing maybe is
coincidence I'll tell you what you get a
video like that you get a video like
Louisville and then you have these two
people sitting in their house when when
a mob breaks their gate down yep okay
little exaggerated at some point the
gate got broken down but they're
entering private prop up and somehow you
know it didn't get and there's a sign
saying nope no yeah in the video it's
just open it's not broken or anything
but they clearly got in there no the
photo the photos that were taken later
showed up it was just yeah later on but
people were already in there when it
showed the people walking through the
gate the gate
Oh fine at that point here's what here's
what I see happening right you have
these people go on Facebook or whatever
and their friends like are you gonna
come down to protest cuz we're gonna go
protest the mayor and they're like oh my
god that's so cool I totally want to
protest and they show up and they're
handed a sign cuz typically they'll make
much signs and hand them out and then
you get these really dumb you know
20-somethings who are alike I'm mad
about something I've never researched
I'm mad about something I've ever
researched and then they organize it
that is it right there then the
organizers open up the gate to a private
lot and they go right this way my
friends and they're like yeah I met I
have no idea where I'm going but you go
ahead I'm gonna wait out here on the the
legal where we're legally allowed to
protest I'm sure that's what happened -
and then why are these people yelling
it's a it's a public street because they
have no idea what's happening around
them exactly it's dangerous man but it's
very clear the no trespassing sign yep
it's on the t-shirt right in the front
of the gate it's like no trespassers the
only sign on the gate let me tell you
story man when I was like 16 I think I
got asked by some chick off like MySpace
or something to come with her to a
protest ok it was an it was an Iraq war
protest I think in Chicago okay
and I was like yeah I'm down I hate the
war right yeah sure I want to get laid
well no for me I was like just I was
like I'm just messing me man good I was
like dude I I was I was punk rock I was
writing all these punk rock songs and I
was like yeah yeah and so I showed up
and we like marched around and like the
loop or whatever some far-left 'hey you
know dudes maybe I came amber hold it
maybe I was 17 or 18 but these like you
know far Lafitte types in all black
we're shoving cops knocking him down and
like the bleeding-heart type hippie
liberals who are organizing it got angry
and they're like stop stop don't do this
and like push them away yeah I'm like
help the cop back up we marched around
and then finally we got to I think it
was Grant Park Millenial Park whatever
they named it okay and then someone
announced the protest is now going to
join the teachers strike and I was like
what the but now the teachers teachers
and college professors were striking at
a nearby university so they were like
everybody go join them and I was like no
what I was like I don't care about their
salaries yeah talking about war in a
foreign country they all went up and
joined them Wow and so I stopped and
some of the some of these like final tea
types were straggling behind and once
they started to walk into the park this
one woman turns around she goes are you
coming you're gonna join us and I got
really angry and I was like they're
talking about getting more money for
their six-figure cushy job or whatever
as tenured professors yeah and we're
talking about war in a foreign country
snaps and I was like half these people
and if anybody who's gonna walk away I'm
gonna keep them I'm gonna keep walking
yeah and by myself I just left and I was
like that was really disillusioning for
me I was like these people aren't what
they're talking about
these people who are marching just
joined a strike and then pretended like
they knew why only these people cared
and I was like get out of here do you
have no idea you're talking about you've
done no research you have no I do these
people all you have no idea what they're
fighting for you just go and stand there
it's because it's because of the cool
points they want to be cool what's cool
standing up for for the minority
standing up against the man it's like
one of the guy who's talking about
testing or something
it's like it's cars looking at it's like
unless you actually know the research
and understand what you're doing what
are you doing thanks for checking out
this clip from the Tim cast IRL podcast
we do the show live Monday through
Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to catch
the full show tune in to this channel
subscribe hit the like button or check
us out on iTunes and Spotify and we will
soon have this podcast up for free on
all podcast platforms thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all in the next
episode
you